in this video I want to talk about the
signaling cascade for insulin so insulin
is a peptide hormone or ply peptide
hormone and of course that means that
it's a polar hormone so it's going to
act and bind a cell surface receptor
insulin is initially synthesized as
zymogen Rianne inactive precursor called
pre pro insulin which is
Clevedon and turned into pro insulin and
that is later turned into insulin the
active form now that insulin is released
specifically from the beta cells of the
islets of Langerhans in the pancreas so
cuckoo yawn was released from the alpha
cells insulin is released from the beta
cells now insulin you might have
actually heard of that term before and
you might have heard it referred to
diabetics which we'll talk about later
insulin responds to high blood glucose
levels if it's too high lower it
that's what insulin does so it acts on
liver muscle and adipose which is of
course fat cells to decrease blood
glucose levels so how does it do that
variety of ways so anything that
decreases blood glucose levels is
something that insulin will activate
does glyco says deep baikal assists
decreased blood glucose levels yes it
breaks down glucose so it'll it'll
increase glycolysis will glycogen
synthesis decrease blood glucose levels
yeah it does because it takes glucose
from being free-floating to being valid
as part of a glycogen chain so it'll
also increase glycogen synthesis
will it increase or decrease fatty acid
synthesis it'll increase fatty acid
synthesis basically because fatty acid
synthesis is a way to store energy if
you have what glucose level around then
you could take that glucose and
eventually just store it as a fatty acid
in addition it can also increase the
translocation of glucose transport
protein which is glute 4 to the plasma
membrane basically glute 4 is a channel
protein that allows glucose to flow into
the cells so if there are cells in your
if there's glucose in your blood you
want to take that glucose out of your
blood and into your cells so insulin
will stimulate the uptake of glucose
from the blood into your cells so how
does this work it doesn't happen via
g-protein coupled receptor instead this
happens we via a receptor tyrosine
kinase instead so here's how it works
and it's not totally understood this
whole scheme it's actually very very
complex I've simplified it greatly here
essentially what happens is insulin
comes over and binds this tyrosine
receptor kinase now there are two alpha
subunits and two beta subunits insulin
will come and bind the alpha subunits
and when that does this whole system
sort of dimerizes and there are these
little tyrosine residues on this the
beta or the cytoplasmic side of these
beta subunits and these tyrosine
residues can auto phosphorylate
themselves or write that here auto
phosphorylation so these tyrosine
residues can end up having little
phosphate groups tacked onto them and
they can also tart or initiate the
phosphorylation of certain target
proteins that have tyrosine residues
so the tyrosine residues on certain
Tiger target proteins will be
phosphorylated now once these target
proteins are phosphorylated they can
have some sort of cellular response now
obviously the situation is much more
complex than that and even today it's
still not completely understood so but I
hope that simplification was a little
bit helpful and it's important to
realize that this insulin triggers a
cascade you know in a different fashion
it reset via receptor tyrosine kinase as
opposed to a g-protein coupled receptor
I hope that brief overview was helpful I
am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email at move University at gmail.com
see the description below for more
details thank you for watching